it's a cult and the
ruling class is enforcing the
orthodoxies of this cult don lemon
on cnn
is furious
at the anti-vaxxers
who won't go along with dr fauci he says
they're stupid and they should not
participate in society
we need to stop listening to the people
and they they should not be part of
um polite society so to speak i can't do
my own research better than experts
who's who have devoted their lives to
medical and and scientific research when
i tell people i said but you know
they'll say well i've been doing my own
research and uh last week i was in miami
i said how did you get to miami i flew
that's science
so if you don't believe in science why
didn't you walk
right if you it did it as well because i
can't always follow the science that's
the reason that you're here that's the
reason that you don't have polio that's
where we don't see polio cases that's
the reason why we don't see smallpox
cases is because your parents had the
wherewithal and the sense to get you
vaccinated as a child so i don't told
that they had to that you had to because
what we have to start doing things for
the greater good of society and not for
idiots who think that they can do their
own research or that they are above the
law
don lemon is saying i don't know
anything i don't do my own research i'm
completely ignorant i blindly follow the
experts
and if you don't do that you're stupid
if you do your own research and come to
your own opinions you're a dumb idiot
you dummy you shouldn't be allowed to
participate in polite society
if if you had your way we'd still have
polio running rampant and smallpox and
all other sorts of diseases
by the way one i think one of the major
drivers for why those diseases no longer
exist is just basic
improvement to sanitation i'm not saying
the vaccines didn't play a role but but
also the reason that public health has
improved actually until until very
recently where you see certain public
health measures have actually gone down
considerably including life expectancy
but before then the reason that public
health measures generally have improved
has not just been because of vaccines
though sure that's played a role but
it's because people are less cramped now
they have more
disinfectants they have more sanitation
they that's a big drive they have better
nutrition they all of these things play
a role
but
if you say that if you have any kind of
balanced view of what's going on in the
public health you're called an idiot
you're called an anti-vaxxer
by the zealots of this of this religion
i'm glad you like that clip
ring the bell subscribe get the
notifications head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
wherever you get your audio podcast
subscribe for free to the michael
knowles show leave a five star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you